Good morning John.
A month and a half ago I got on a plane and
flew to Los Angeles, California.
First stop off of the plane: In-N-Out Burger.
My cashier was a fan of SciShow!
Second stop: my hotel, where I was asked by
the check-in person whether or not I was there
to party.
Seeing no sign that I was here to party, I
assumed he was joking.
So I said something to the effect of like
"Duh, what part of this package with the baggy
eyes and the nerd... thirty-four year old
dirty T-shirt-wearing guy makes you think
that I'm not 100% turning down for what?"
But it turned out he was not joking, because
he then told me twenty different parties that
were happening within a block and the dress
codes for those, which I had no way of achieving.
Turned out I was not just in Los Angeles,
John; I was in Hollywood.
Staying at the Roosevelt Hotel.
Advertised on Google Maps as having a celeb-friendly
nightclub and pool.
I don't know what that means.
It was a secret why I was in LA, and that
annoyed me because so many interesting and
weird things happened, and the whole point
of being a video blogger is that when weird
things happen to you, you get to share them.
But now, I CAN share the reason I was in Los
Angeles.
I was there as part of this thing where YouTube
is promoting YouTube channels.
They were taking pictures and videos of me
an Michael Aranda and Caitlin Hofmeister for
the SciShow promotion, print advertisement
and television advertisement campaigns, which
are now a thing in the real world all over
the place: in Chicago, in Los Angeles, in
New York, and on television, during the Walking
Dead premiere, during the Big Bang Theory,
during Late Night with Jimmy Fallon...
The Walking Dead premiere was viewed by seventeen
million people, and all the people that didn't
TiVo through the advertisements saw ME.
What did they think?
What did they think about?
Probably not much.
Usually when you see an advertisement, you're
like uhhaouwjevba.
Hopefully, I subconsciously influenced them
into thinking that science is still cool and
that they are still curious about the world,
no matter what zombie pandemic is on the way.
Here's the thing about Walking Dead zombies:
they've been dead forever, and they're not
eating anything; there's not enough humans
left to create fuel for them, but somehow
they are magically able to continue moving.
What powers them - are they photosynthetic?!
Maybe they're somehow tapped into dark energy
and that's powering them.
If we could end the zombie apocalypse and
capture some of them and put them, like, in
hamster wheels with like a brain on the other
side of the wheel and they could just climb
after it forever, it would be infinite free
power!
We could go from the zombie apocalypse to
a complete utopia!
I'm just sayin'!
Anyway, how I feel about being on TV and on
the side of buses and subway cars is that
I don't know how I feel.
A big piece of me understands that this is
a big deal, and it searches the rest of the
me for thing that I'm feeling about it, and
it is unable to find a feeling.
The disconnected for me thoughts are like:
is this good for SciShow?
And I hope it is because I think that more
SciShow is better for the world, because we
really do need to be a more scientifically
literate society, and I think that SciShow
does a fairly good job of that as compared
to television science stuff.
And then another piece of me is: are these
campaigns in general, it's more than just
SciShow, good for online video as a thing?
The goal of the campaign isn't about SciShow;
it's about making Youtube seem like a legitimate
place to spend your time as a viewer, and
as a legitimate place for advertisers to spend
their money.
It's about welcoming far more people and also
more money into this medium than has ever
been here before.
And I'm a little ambivalent about that because
as the Youtube community becomes so big and
multifaceted that it breaks from that singular
Youtube community into plural Youtube communities,
Youtube, as a thing, is a little bit less
special if it's mainstream.
Which is why I'm so extremely happy that Vlogbrothers
is way too weird to ever be actually mainstream!
And we are dedicated to that!
We will not allow Vlogbrothers to be unweird
enough for it to be mainstream!
THIS HAS TO BE WEIRD!
I just grabbed you right by the neck, there.
THE PIZZA JOHN HAS TO HUMP THE PUPPY SIZED
ELEPHANT WHILE SWOODILYPOOPING IN AGLOE, NEW
YORK!
DEATH TO PENNIES, JOHN!
I'll see you on Tuesday.